(lively, bouncy piano music)
- Walking around a refugee camp,
you just see rows and rows of tents.
The trauma that these
people have experienced
is just so severe and life-consuming,
so I'm bringing dance to this refugee camp
as a therapy tool.
This camp is filled with refugees who have
had to flee their homes because of ISIS.
This displacement has really
just taken everything,
including their will to even try,
because of the hopelessness
that comes from being a refugee.
I'm studying dance at Belhaven University,
but I've always been really interested
in how dance can be taken off the stage,
and that's when I really began to see
a greater scope with dance
and that maybe it could
be used for something
more than just myself.
One.
When this opportunity came
about for me to volunteer
at the center as a dance teacher,
I really just couldn't resist.
These children's desire
to move is so great.
They just took the class
and there was laughter
and smiles immediately,
regardless of language barriers.
We use a lot of motion
and a lot of pointing,
and arrows, and directions,
and we communicate
with our bodies.
Good job.
Dance is this really amazing vessel
for which healing can take place,
because it involves
physicality and connecting
with yourself and your body.
That's kind of a missing piece.
There's a lot of focus on your mind
and your thoughts and your emotions,
and then sometimes the body is left out.
Sometimes we label refugees as refugees,
and that's all that they are,
but they have the same
needs that you and I have
to be creative and to
move, and to breathe,
and to engage with their humanity.
I think having a creative
outlet within a camp
is so necessary, because
it's not only fulfilling
those needs for food and shelter,
but also fulfilling that need
for them as human beings.
(chiming)